[Music]
listen on this occasion I'm only sitting
the previous Leons because this
episode's 46 minute run time hardly
seems long enough to wrap everything up
especially when I'm hoping 30 of those
minutes are just dedicated to Balin slow
combing his beard is it just me or does
this shot manage to be phallic yonic and
sexually penetrative all at once just me
liar Grand Admiral
the cargo transfer is complete thank
goodness I've been waiting so long for
them to finish with this cargo transfer
it's eaten up like 30% of The Season's
plot I can't wait for the payoff that'll
come from showing me what's inside those
boxes you're not going to show me what's
inside those boxes are you come on
what's in the
box there is little the Jedi can do to
stop us now yeah but you only know that
because Darth filon already announced
he's making a movie to tie up the new
Republic shows I don't care if you're a
witch reading the script is cheating she
who heard our dreams across the stars
all right so back in episode one i s the
Magic Orb knowing where thraw is and
this is what I said I have a funny
feeling it basically comes down to the
force did it and if I'm wrong I'll write
and perform an apology song to the tune
of the Star Wars theme while juggling
lightsabers well it's clearly because of
some witchy powers and not the force and
as I'm a man of my word I present to you
my apology with lightsaber
juggling I am so very
sorry so very sorry
sorry
sorry oh my
arm huh it does cauterize the whole
thing the
blade tson you know what Jo I am done
going to Wikipedia to understand
references to cartoons and books from
the last few years I will instead reward
you with our own patented blade of talin
okay this might be one of the wittiest
episode titles in the history of episode
titling makes sense for the story the
syllables line up hell wardrobe and
warlord even start the same but did
someone forget that we're dealing with
some serious Galaxy threatening sh here
a witty pun is not the shift in tone I
was expecting the blade emitter is too
narrow ha haa people complain the
lightsabers were too skinny in the
cartoon very funny self-aware reference
just build your damn lightsaber also I
didn't have Disney adapts Galaxy's Edge
build a lightsaber Workshop into a
liveaction scene on my sin card but here
we are what happened between those two
save your breath Ezra we've been wanting
to know the same thing all season but it
doesn't look like Ahsoka became afraid
that Sabine was training as a Jedi for
the wrong reasons after what happened on
mandor oh so you're telling him did no
one think that crucial bit of backstory
might have helped us understand their
relationship a bit more also Ahsoka felt
her Padawan might risk falling to the
dark side and just decided to stop
training her makes sense I mean can you
imagine if sine just woke up to find her
master trying to kill her she slept
that'd be so ridiculous and out of
character
your gamble paid off hold your forces
there Ahsoka you can't claim the gamble
has paid off until all the holographic
cards have been revealed if th makes it
back to your Galaxy that is the very
definition of the gamble not paying off
so you know no she just took a trip on a
space wheel to another galaxy because
some other witch got their hands on a
one-of-kind map ball that was given to
them by one of ahsoka's other former
padle yes of course youing knew you
didn't destroy the orb sorry are you
though you didn't trip over your armor
and fumble that ball into in's hands
that was a definite and considered
choice you made Choice I'm pretty
confident you'd make again Own It sine
own the fact that you possibly wreck the
Galaxy mere years after it freed itself
oh that over the years I've made my
share of difficult choices yeah but did
any of those choices ever risk bringing
back the greatest threat to peace in the
Galaxy often no one understood my
reasons except my master Anakin using
Anakin as your benchmark for rational
decision- making is a choice being a
Jedi isn't about wielding a light
superer oh you're funny Star Wars I
almost think you mean that sorry sorry
sorry sorry no no no no no seriously say
it again say it again I can keep a
straight face this time being a
Jedi isn't about wielding a light
superer hey let's go just finished
exactly in time to see Tie fighters
conveniently arrive is how I think
wanted to finish that
sentence I know the fighters technically
hit the engines but this ship is an
absolute tiptoeing Sitting Duck and they
had all of the run up to get these shots
in this quarterback should be toast and
on the second run they miss it entirely
the very least the first starting run
should have been to get your eye on the
target so you can lock in and obliterate
that on the return run and these guys
never played Star Wars TIE
fighter I really don't know how we can
ever take the Empire seriously when the
insanely maneuverable Tie fighters are
piloted by dumb asses that think
covering their helmeted faces as they
fly directly into the enemy is their
best course of
action ahus t61 974 survives this hm I
really should have given that a sexier
name or at least something easier to say
like Sith Slayer or the indat indee in
inder inder you know what t61 974 is
totally fine so sorry to State the
obvious this is going to slow us down a
bit I mean it can't slow you down any
more than traveling with the space crabs
right how fast where you're going like 3
miles per hour my pug runs faster than
that when I'm popping popcorn only if we
let it which is ahsoka's way of saying
those now defenseless Turtle Gremlins
we've befriended let's leave them
utterly stranded and open to attack as
we Gallop towards our ticket home
consider all of the Tie fighters lost
mark their Captain for a citation I hope
that citation is for Trooper most likely
to disappoint the Empire by being a
dumbass in the face of underwhelming
odds their options to prevent that
departure are now severely limited if
not impossible typical Star Wars villain
underestimates the good guys instead
which is why we should prepare for a
ground assault oh kind of took the wind
out of my sales there thrwy wait is this
an intelligent Star Wars villain what
that's not my Star Wars now we have a
phallic Tower of magic entering a yonic
symbol of fascism which is also being
docked by ionic piece of technology and
please tell me I'm still not the only
one seeing this The Rock from a far far
away Galaxy are able to make sense of
the strange technology on this ship and
help Huang repair it while I still burn
my toast every morning Thon found this
place woke up the witches rebuilt his
Starship I don't think we can overstate
how lucky thron he got he landed on a
planet that just happened to be
inhabited by exiled witches who not only
had knowledge of a map to this galaxy
but also had access to a sister witch
working for the Empire who could help
them it's amazing he landed on a planet
with life on it at all also are we
really going to just skip over how he
woke up the great mothers were they dead
in stasis we could have had an entire
episode dedicated to thraw finding this
Ancient Temple braving the catacombs and
waking up these magical beings instead
it's brushed over in a single sentence
ring Hellfire upon them this really
should have worked like really this is a
star destroyer unleashing Fury against
three squishy people and Thon knows
exactly where they're heading yes
they're using the forcex mocking it a
hell but only up into the point they
start focusing on opening the doors how
are they dodging the fire then I shall
inform the great mothers that it's time
time for what you should have left the
moment Morgan informed you the cargo was
loaded I don't understand why you've
been waiting around for the Jedi to
catch up aside from the script needing
to give our heroes a way to almost win
forgive me for being crude but why can't
we chop some more heads off or even
hands not sparing any lives here they
definitely intend on killing these guys
so why not make it quick and definitive
why are we going for all these slashing
and grazing shots as if we're showing
this on the Disney chant
[Music]
oh we interrupt this episode of Ahsoka
to bring you Hocus Pocus a Star Wars
story zombies Star Wars now has zombies
right this ever happened before no this
is new no it isn't Stormtroopers have
always basically been zombies faceless
fodder that mindlessly attacks and Mass
to give the good guys something to shoot
at this is just Star Wars finally
admitting it Ste the
door destroying a door panel makes the
door react exactly as you needed to
cliche still not a sex thing still not a
sex thing still not a sex thing the
storming dead were stumped by a door
which actually makes sense considering
they're zombies and all what's confusing
is that they've somehow retained enough
intelligence to precisely set up
explosives along the store to blow it up
oh and I'll handle this we stay together
Remember come on Sabine that [__]
didn't work on cedos and it clearly
doesn't apply here just separate like
you always do until consequences throw
you back together yoshimitsu's mom was
sent down by thraw to stop the Jedi from
getting onto the ship not just to SOA
the Jedi why is she just happily letting
Ezra and saine go wait a second what's
going on here first we have an
intelligent villain and now we have a
still camera watching two characters
fight for 10 whole seconds Star Wars I
don't re recognize you anymore and I
kind of love
it these Troopers playing hide and seek
instead of using this Advantage at all
shouldn't these Mandalorian helmets have
a chin strap on them or a buckle or
something if your opponent can just take
that off midf fight I don't think it's
helme thing efficiently so means
lightsaber falls off of her hip because
it knows she'll appreciate the victory
so much more if she really has to work
for it oh good that's what I came here
to see hey hand toh hand combat between
a Jedi who just built a new lightsaber
and a zombie with a strange level of
hand eye coordination the stakes could
not be higher Ezra Waits until now to
force grab the lightsaber because he
either likes getting his ass thrown
around or wanted s bean to grab hers
first because he didn't want to make her
feel inadequate you can't make that jump
yes you can I appreciate the com I push
you first and you pull me across just a
second now Sabine I mean congrats you
managed to pick up your lightsaber using
the force but even that was a struggle
now you're saying with confidence that
you can help throw Ezra through a force
jump uphill across this huge gap she
pulls this off I have questions about
why Luke and Yoda wereing around on deab
so much there's no time come on oh you
we know Sabine isn't abandoning Ahsoka
the only thing leaving this fight is my
suspension of disbelief as I'm now left
wondering what the she's doing for the
next minute or so while Ahsoka is
getting her ass kicked and lightsaber
destroyed the Stormtrooper suddenly
decided the dealing with the Jedi scum
is a spectator sport and they aren't
qualified to participate and you will
die
here alone not alone if eleth hadn't
tagged her in with that epic setup would
Sabina have ever joined the fight was
she really just standing there waiting
for a witty oneliner also I guess not a
single one of these Troopers who are
literally surrounding this place saw a
bean get into position to deliver this
line Jedi tummy tucks are brutal would
not recommend also I guess the sword
Isn't So Special after all and can be
used by anyone who picks it up much like
Anakin Elizabeth didn't have to
sacrifice her pupils after
all heroes jump into a seeming Abyss
only to be picked up by a flying
companion cliche why did Thon ship
continue to shoot the Fortress instead
of changing targets to Ahsoka ship I
mean it's kind of comforting to have the
villain back to making questionable
decisions but it's still getting dinged
long live the
Empire this dude really got to give an
entire villain mon shortly before
jumping away without any consequences
whatsoever now that feels like a
[Music]
cartoon this bird in the nonsense
metaphor it flew in on giving us barely
30 seconds of bailin instead of the 30
minutes I reasonably demanded at the top
of this video I know the show's trying
to set up a cute reveal for Ezra but in
what Universe would they allow an
unknown ship to land and not open fire
Upon A person wearing the enemy's armor
in reality Ezra ship got blown up on
approach and he's a force ghost by now
also the episode decides to give us
thrawn and Prejudice and Zombies instead
of Ezra presumably epic escape from
thon's Star Destroyer I did well did I
Thon Got Away Ezra got home and all it
cost was stranding two of his closest
friends in the same place he's been
stranded and the return of the last and
most deadly Imperial warlord I haven't
seen a trade this unbalance since I
swapped my shiny charizard for a packet
of jelly beans I was hungry
Ezra is where he needs to be and so are
we by that logic what was the point of
even trying if we're all going to end up
where we're supposed to be I may as well
just stay on the sofa watching Star Wars
all day which is totally different from
what I'm doing now of course it's
time to move on thing everyone keeps
telling Dave filon about the Clone War
somehow makes it into the script I hope
when I'm a ghost I get to come back to a
point in my life before I've killed a
bunch of younglings and caused Decades
of pain across an entire
galaxy
what's everyone's problem I'm glad we're
stranded it is for the
Empire the security of our galaxy you're
my boy blue you're my
[Music]
boy mes Trum s
Duna M Trum
D the Star Wars holiday
special starring Mark Hamill as Luke
[Music]
Skywalker finish
her fatality
[Music]
[Applause]
any zombies out there don't say that
what that what that the dead word don't
say it why not because it's
[Applause]
[Music]
ridiculous over the hills and far
away tet tubes come to
play at this rate they make it on board
the ship which would be
problematic we require a little more
time I don't want to go